(percussive music)
- [Narrator] Vinegar is one of the oldest
fermented foods in the world,
but these days it seems to
be having a bit of a moment.
In the town of Kagoshima in Japan,
you will find a special dark vinegar
that has long been ahead of the times.
- [Announcer] This Great
Big Story is inspired by
Genesis.
(lyrical music)
(speaks in a foreign language)
- [Narrator] Tadaaki
is the brewmaster here
at the Sakamoto Jouzu Brewery.
(speaks in a foreign language)
(bouncy music)
The vinegar ferments in
special vases called tsubos
for over a year.
(speaks in a foreign language)
This aging process is
what separates kurozu
from other vinegars.
The longer the vinegar ferments
the darker it will become,
and the smoother it will taste.
(speaks in a foreign language)
In Kagoshima you can also
find vinegar smoothies,
(speaks in a foreign language)
soups, drinks, sauces,
people can't seem to get enough of it.
(quiet music)
Tadaaki has been a brewmaster
since he was 40 years old,
and for him, the job can't be beat.
(speaks in a foreign language)
(chiming)